[Musique]
vous connaissez mon parcours je sais que
vous êtes un homme politique vous êtes
lumière de lyon ont payé le prix le
meyrignat bien je vais essayer de vous
exposer ma situation j'ai toujours eu
des idées
j'avais 25 40 50 idées par jour non non
oui et puis je me suis réveillé un matin
j'avais plus d'idées j'arrive plus à
penser comment vous vous appelez à 10 mn
bon allez c'est man il faut que vous
fassiez penser
[Musique]
je vais être brusque allez-y n'ai pas
l'impression de ne plus pouvoir régler
un seul problème
moi je pense que c'est saison les
citoyens ont l'impression cela excusez
moi nous attend non mais attends pas en
battant mois on veut distribuer ça à
tout le monde et vous leur dites que il
remplace et annule autre discours au
caire son nouveau bureau créé un énorme
scandale à la nuit scandale et même une
pétition qui circule il faut rester
modeste part de mégalomanie par le
gigantisme
ça va aller note savvas les notes je
fais pas à court sur spinoza ali salmane
sk prend des notes compagne note
l'influencent que tu es sur lui il faut
qu'elle cesse en fait en train de me
dire qu il de nouveau arrêté de penser
ça je suis désolé mais je n'ai plus le
même et je te remercie alice alice on va
écrire tous les deux le discours de ma
vie
[Musique]